so Megan everyone knows that you like to
keep it real on social media and life in
general so can you explain what's going
on in this video your brother's shot
my peach
here's these here's oh you cut yourself
listen I'm not good at it okay it's made
me nervous you started booming me out of
nowhere I was like doing Australian Idol
I was a judge and I people don't talk
about this let's talk about it
I everyone so peach fuzz right yeah the
older you get
no literally I'm like what I'm a peach
right now like I have so much and I'm
blonde and I'm blonde so then when I go
in the sun it looks like I'm a Twilight
vampire because I glisten my beard will
glisten I feel it like in lips are
moving the music video they're like
we're gonna do a close-up on your lips I
was like
such like why did Noah tell me and so on
like big important days I'll shave when
I know we're doing a music video I would
shave the night before the day of I
shaved out there with a new razor type
thing and I sliced myself and my
brother's like oh boy you know he was
like this isn't good you're on TV
tonight but I literally have to yeah I
don't do it because I'm lazy but my
mind I always make the jokes I always
make the joke I'm like I'm like are you
gonna shave my beard is that what we're
doing right now yeah and I'm like
because there's so much Peach food you
have to get all of it or else there's
like a line like yeah it's like a line
of my makeup artist what have you done I
was like did I miss a spot she's like I
know and it always catches the Sun at
like the perfect yeah anyway that's real
we're hairy super attractive
um at least it's blonde at least like
yeah we're lucky
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
guys I'm going home
[Music]